[Music]
airbnb
is huge today on any given night you
could have
as many as two million people staying in
an airbnb
all around the world you know our
mission is that everyone
can belong anywhere we're talking you
know 300 million stays
on any average year and there's tyranny
in numbers
the vast majority of airbnb stays don't
result in a safety incident
but sometimes things go wrong and for
airbnb
you know we're talking thousands of
safety incidents that occur every year
that the company has to handle and has
to respond to
i'm talking situations like kidnappings
hostage cases we're talking
murder we're talking rape we're talking
you know the worst violent crimes that
occur
in our society happen inside airbnbs
airbnb never wants these kinds of cases
to end up in the headlines you know
that's really bad for their
their brand their reputation and their
public image particularly because this
is a business that's based on strangers
trusting one another
so when crimes like this occur that kind
of threatens their entire business model
[Music]
i'm olivia carville i'm a reporter on
bloomberg's technology team
and i've been covering online travel
companies like airbnb
for the last two years
airbnb is a startup that's based in
silicon valley
and like many of the sharing economy
startups it managed to grow
so big so fast by essentially skirting
regulations
[Music]
it was based on that premise of move
fast and break things and
it wanted to work against regulations in
order to grow as big as possible
and win the popular vote because it
became so popular so fast
that cities could no longer control it
on a peak night this past
august we had one million people from
around the world
coming from 180 countries in a single
night staying
in an airbnb home the vast majority of
airbnb
stays we're talking you know two million
people staying in an airbnb on any given
night
don't result in a safety incident but
sometimes
things go wrong
[Music]
and for the company you know it was
dealing with these cases was a really
challenging difficult
complicated area you had hosts and
guests and sometimes they disagreed on
what happened
you had regulatory issues in some of
their biggest cities
then you also had you know the growth of
the platform and the fact that if you're
going to try and prevent some of these
incidents
it could cut into revenue and cut into
the number of listings that you have
so for airbnb it was about trying to
figure out
the best way to handle these crises in a
way that's going to not only protect the
individual in crisis
but also protect the company's public
image its brand
its reputation which is essentially what
its business is based upon
as airbnb grew like way too big for them
to be able to take all these calls alone
they developed a team of 100 highly
specialized agents that handle the worst
of the worst cases
over the course of my reporting i've
talked to almost 50 former employees at
airbnb and you know seven or eight of
those work directly on this elite unit
these safety agents many of them come
from military backgrounds
or trauma backgrounds they're trained to
handle
traumatic situations and to try and you
know help people who are going through
what what may be you know the worst day
in their lives
for these safety agents a lot of them
understood that they had a dual role
first and foremost they wanted to
protect the user in crisis
but they also knew they had a
responsibility to protect the company's
brand and public image
i mean everything about housing in new
york is a total mess and it's always
chaotic it's not too surprising that
airbnb's biggest battle has broken out
here
2015 was a really challenging year for
airbnb
airbnb's listings between 2010 and 2014
were essentially illegal hotels you know
the company was seven years old now
um it had grown huge it was now a
household name
but by growing that big that fast they
also
came up against you know a pushback and
regulations
now airbnb is under attack in a lot of
majors what are they saying about this i
mean they are well
look they can't give up on new york
because new york's too important for
every kind of reason
they knew that they couldn't lose the
battle in new york because
it was one of their biggest markets and
also it could result in a domino effect
if other cities around america saw new
york city
either backing down on regulations or
enforcing stricter regulations
that could in turn be rolled out right
across the country
i think it's going to be awkward when
they have to you know put in their
prospectus their risk factors when they
have to say well you know one risk is
that the whole thing might be somewhat
illegal in
in our biggest market and in december of
that year
a young woman from australia flew into
new york and stayed at an airbnb with a
group of her friends
they picked up a key from the local
corner bodega
without even needing identification the
police report
said this 29 year old woman left her
friends at a midtown bar
and returned to the airbnb on her own
she thought that she was alone but she
wasn't
there was a man inside the apartment
hiding in the shadows
with a kitchen knife
he grabbed her dragged her into a room
and raped her he later fled
[Music]
about an hour after this attack he came
back
and police were in the apartment at the
time they opened his backpack
and found three items of interest the
kitchen knife
one of the women's earrings and a set of
keys
to the airbnb
this case was a really complicated one
for airbnb
partly because it occurred in new york
city where they were fighting this
really
tough battle with city officials over
regulations
and partly because the alleged rapist
had the keys and he was
inside the apartment that meant that
airbnb
needed to do what it could to to protect
itself they wanted to find out
you know how did he get the keys that
was a really big question for them they
launched an investigation to find that
out
but before they did anything like that
before they thought to kind of protect
their own reputation here
they really focused on doing what they
could to help this young woman
they paid for her to move to a hotel
they paid for her mother to fly in from
australia
they paid for both of them to fly home
they offered to cover any health or
lee or counselling costs that she might
need later
but inside the company internally they
also launched an investigation
they wanted to know how did the alleged
rapist get the keys
how did he get inside that airbnb and
when they found out
that the keys had been left at the
corner bodega
that then created you know a problem of
liability for airbnb
they didn't have a policy around key
exchange they didn't tell their hosts
how they did or didn't have to
hand keys over to guests as they were
arriving
so for airbnb they also you know they
wanted to know what was going to be said
in court
they wanted to know if any media were
going to pick up on this story
and they wanted to know what their legal
liability potentially could be
a week later the alleged rapist was
indicted
in the supreme court in new york and
airbnb
sent a staff member to find out if the
company was going to be mentioned in any
of the court records
and it wasn't it wasn't mentioned in the
police report it wasn't mentioned by
prosecutors
there's no mention of airbnb really in
any public record
this case has never been reported until
now
and you know for airbnb that was kind of
lucky this case never landed
in the media and you know 18 months
later
when this woman's lawyer reached out to
the company
they signed a settlement for seven
million dollars and part of that
settlement
there's a clause that says she cannot
assert or imply responsibility on the
part of the company
we've spoken to legal experts who
indicate that what this really did
is gag the woman from saying i blame
[Music]
[Music]
airbnb
[Music]
airbnb is one of the few companies in
the world
that has this like online offline kind
of
hybrid situation where you have users
who
meet online and then actually
meet in the offline world and stay under
the same roof
and that means that the company at the
end of the day
really has to take more responsibility
than other social media platforms might
do
with airbnb's terms of service that
really means that whenever there's a
dispute between hosts and guests and the
company
this is all handled behind closed doors
and arbitration
most of these cases don't even make it
to the courtroom and when they do
the company will settle them so it
doesn't go on through the courts
and what that means is that there hasn't
really been
a legal precedent that's set to
determine what airbnb's liability is
here
you know is it really responsible for
when things go wrong inside its listings
[Music]
what i learned over the course of my
reporting is that this is anything but
simple
this is a complicated nuanced area
there are difficult trade-offs here the
company
also has to have hard you know tough
conversations about policy
airbnb's business model is based on
strangers trusting one another
we often hear from the founders and the
chief executive himself saying
trust is their number one priority i've
actually heard brian chesky the chief
executive of airbnb
talking about how he didn't build a
website or a platform
that allows people to stay in each
other's homes what he built
was a community that trusts one another
and when that premise is undercut
airbnb's entire business model is under
threat
you